REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER DON
BALDIC.
NEW HAMPSHIRE'S SEAT IS CRITICAL
TO THE DEMOCRATS' CHANCES OF
HOLDING CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
>>> ALSO TONIGHT, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY SPEAKING
OUT TODAY ABOUT THE BRUTAL
ATTACK ON HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI'S HUSBAND, PAUL, CALLING
IT WRONG.
WE'RE HEARING FROM HIM ABOUT THE
INCIDENT FOR THE FIRST TIME.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
VIOLENCE OR THREATS OF VIOLENCE
HAVE NO PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY.
WHAT HAPPENED TO PAUL PELOSI WAS
WRONG.
I REACHED OUT TO THE SPEAKER, I
CALLED HER, SHE WAS ON A PLANE
COMING BACK TO CALIFORNIA.
I WAS ABLE TO TEXT WITH HER,
TELL HER ABOUT MY CONCERNS ABOUT
PAUL.
THANKFULLY HE'LL BE OKAY.
THE ATTACKER WAS A DERANGED
INDIVIDUAL, BUT THANKFULLY HE
WAS ARRESTED.
>> REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JAMES
COMBER FROM KENTUCKY JOINS US,
POISED TO BECOME CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE IF
REPUBLICANS WIN THE MAJORITY IN
THE MIDTERMS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR COMING
ON THE SHOW.
FIRST OFF, DO YOU JOIN KEVIN
McCARTHY IN CONDEMNING THE
ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI?
McCARTHY, AS YOU CERTIFIED, SAID
WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM IS FLAT-OUT
WRONG.
>> OF COURSE.
I MEAN, I CONDEMN ANY ATTACK OF
POLITICAL VIOLENCE FROM ANYONE
OF EITHER PARTY.
IT'S WRONG.
I'VE SAID FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW,
THE RHETORIC KEEPS GETTING WORSE
AND WORSE.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
ENVIRONMENT OUT THERE.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
GET SO FIRED UP BECAUSE OF
VARIOUS POLITICAL CAUSES.
IT PUTS MANY POLITICIANS IN A
DANGEROUS SPOT.
>> I WANT TO FOCUS ON THIS IN
PARTICULAR, BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI
HAS BEEN DEMONIZED BY THE GOP
FOR YEARS.
THE ATTACKER WAS SHOUTING
"WHERE'S NANCY?"
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT WE HEARD
ON JANUARY 6th FROM RIOTERS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING PELOSI IS THE TOP
MEMBER MALIGNED IN POLITICAL ADS
AHEAD OF THE MIDTERMS ACCORDING
TO AD IMPACT.
SHOULD YOUR COLLEAGUES TONE DOWN
THE RHETORIC HERE?
AND ALSO BAT AWAY SOME OF THESE
CONSPIRACIES, THAT THIS ATTACKER
WAS APPARENTLY TALKING ABOUT
ONLINE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT PEOPLE IN
BOTH PARTIES SHOULD TONE DOWN
THE RHETORIC --
>> I SAID WHAT ABOUT -- LET'S
TALK ABOUT THE GOP.
WE SAW THE HUSBAND OF HOUSE
SPEAKER, BEING ATTACKED WITH A
HAMMER, SHE IS HEAVILY MALIGNED
AND DEMONIZED BY THE RIGHT.
GO AHEAD.
>> YEAH, NO, AND SHE'S DEMONIZED
AS IS MITCH McCONNELL AND CHUCK
SCHUMER AND I'M SURE KEVIN
McCARTHY WHEN HE BECOMES SPEAKER
WILL BE DEMONIZED.
IT'S A TERRIBLE ENVIRONMENT.
AND I BELIEVE PEOPLE IN BOTH
PARTIES ARE GUILTY OF INTENSE
RHETORIC THAT REALLY LEADS TO
FEED INTO THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DERANGED.
AND CREATE VIOLENCE.
IT'S THE SAME THING THAT
HAPPENED WITH THE SHOOTER THAT
SHOT AT STEVE SCALISE AND
SEVERAL OF THE REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES.
VIOLENCE IS WRONG.
THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE PUT IN
JAIL FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIFE.
AND YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO TRY TO
DO BETTER IN BOTH PARTIES.
MYSELF INCLUDED.
>> WELL, THAT'S BIG OF YOU TO
INCLUDE YOURSELF IN THAT.
BUT I AM JUST CURIOUS.
I MEAN, JUST HONESTLY HERE,
WHY -- THE OTHER ATTACKS, STEVE
SCALISE, LEE ZELDIN, WHITE HOUSE
DID CONDEMN THAT.
WHY -- AND OTHER DEMOCRATS DID
TOO, VERY QUICK TO CONDEMN THAT
AND THOSE CASES.
WHY IN THIS CASE DOES THERE HAVE
TO BE, WELL, THERE'S ALSO AN
ADDENDUM, A QUALIFIER?
WHY CAN'T IT BE JUST, NO, THIS
IS REALLY BAD, AND WE DENOUNCE
THIS VIOLENCE AGAINST PAUL
PELOSI, AND YES, WE SHOULD LOWER
THE RHETORIC ON OUR SIDE?
WHY DO WE HAVE TO BRING IN THE
OTHER SIDE ON SOMETHING LIKE
THIS?
>> I MEAN, I BELIEVE THAT THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERS -- I KNOW
SCALISE TWEETED OUT EARLY ON,
THAT'S WHERE I LEARNED ABOUT IT.
I FOLLOW SCALISE ON TWITTER.
AND THEN I GOT A MESSAGE THAT
McCARTHY HAD SENT OUT THAT HE
HAD TRIED TO REACH NANCY PELOSI
AND OFFERED HIS PRAYERS TO HER.
I MEAN, I THINK THAT REPUBLICANS
WERE QUICK TO CONDEMN THE
VIOLENCE.
LOOK, WE'VE GOT A -- WE'RE OFTEN
OUT THERE, WE ALL HIT TOWN HALLS
WHEN THE HEALTH CARE DEBATE WAS
RAGING, THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO
REPEAL HEALTH CARE.
THAT WAS A VERY CHALLENGING
TIME.
THAT WAS MY FRESHMAN YEAR IN
CONGRESS.
AND THE TOWN HALLS GOT OUT OF
HAND.
I HAD SEVERAL GET OUT OF HAND,
EVEN IN MY RURAL KENTUCKY
DISTRICT.
SO THIS IS A TERRIBLE THING.
OUR THOUGHTS GO OUT TO THE
PELOSI FAMILY.
HOPEFULLY THE ATTACKER WILL BE
PUT IN JAIL FOR A LONG TIME.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE COULD GO ON
ABOUT THIS.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
TOPICS TO TALK ABOUT,
CONGRESSMAN.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
REPUBLICANS, INCLUDING YOU, HAVE
SLAMMED DEMOCRATS FOR RISING
INFLATION.
AMERICANS ARE HARD HIT, NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
I WAS JUST IN KENTUCKY WHERE YOU
ARE NOW, TALKING TO KENTUCKIANS.
AND THEY ALL TALKED ABOUT THE
RISING PRICES.
BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING INFLATION
IN PLACES LIKE GREAT BRITAIN,
EUROPE.
IT IS A GLOBAL PROBLEM.
SO WHAT IS THE SPECIFIC
REPUBLICAN PLAN TO IMPROVE THE
ECONOMY?
>> WELL, THE REPUBLICAN PLAN TO
IMPROVE THE ECONOMY IS TWOFOLD.
FIRST OF ALL, WE WANT TO STOP
UNNECESSARY SPENDING BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT'S LED TO A
LOT OF THE INFLATION.
WE'VE HAD STIMULUS IN THE NAME
OF COVID.
WE'VE HAD EXTENDED UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAD THE PPP LOAN PROGRAM,
WHICH I BELIEVE CONTRIBUTED TO
INFLATION.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOVERNMENT
SPENDING WITH THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT WHICH I BELIEVE
REALLY INCREASED INFLATION.
JUST TOO MUCH GOVERNMENT
SPENDING.
SO THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO GET UNNECESSARY SPENDING
UNDER CONTROL.
SECONDLY, WE'VE GOT TO REVERSE
COURSE ON OUR ENERGY POLICY.
I BELIEVE THAT THE BIDEN ENERGY
POLICY IS KIND OF A MODEL OF
WHAT THE GREEN NEW DEAL WOULD
LOOK LIKE.
IT'S, YOU KNOW, TURNED A -- WE
FROWNED ON DRILLING.
WE NEED TO GET OUT OF THE WAY.
THE GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO GET OUT
OF THE WAY OF OUR AMERICAN
ENERGY INDUSTRY.
WE NEED TO LET THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY DO WHAT IT DOES BEST,
PRODUCE ENERGY.
WE CAN BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO GO TO OPEC
AND BEG FOR OIL.
WE CAN PRODUCE THE OIL IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND I BELIEVE RIGHT NOW THE
POLICIES OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
HAVE LED TO HIGHER GAS PRICES,
WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO INFLATION.
NOW WE'VE GOT A POTENTIAL
SHORTAGE OF DIESEL.
THAT COULD NOT ONLY INCREASE
INFLATION, BUT ALSO LEAD TO MORE
CHALLENGES WITH THE SUPPLY CHAIN
SHORTAGES.
SO WE'VE GOT A LOT OF CHALLENGES
IN OUR ECONOMY.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE NEW
LEADERSHIP IN WASHINGTON TO
REVERSE COURSE ON SPENDING AND
OUR ENERGY POLICY.
>> AND YOU SAID A LOT THERE, AND
A LOT OF IT IS BASED ON
DEMOCRATS' POLICIES THAT YOU
DISAGREE WITH.
YOU ALSO MENTIONED PPP, WHICH
WAS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT I'M WONDERING, DO
REPUBLICANS FEEL LIKE THEY DON'T
NEED A PLAN?
BECAUSE VOTERS WILL JUST BLAME
DEMOCRATS?
BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT I HEAR
FROM REPUBLICANS IS ABOUT
DEMOCRATIC POLICIES THAT THEY
DON'T LIKE, THAT THEY THINK IS
HURTING AMERICANS, THOUGH RISING
PRICES ARE SEEN ALL OVER THE
PLACE IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
BUT IS THERE A SENSE THAT, LOOK,
VOTERS ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR
REPUBLICANS ON THE ECONOMY
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BLAME
THE DEMOCRATS?
WE DON'T EVEN NEED A PLAN TO LAY
OUT?
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR, IF
THE POLLING'S RIGHT, THAT THE
VOTERS ARE PRETTY FRUSTRATED
WITH INFLATION.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED WITH CRIME.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHO TO
BLAME, YOU HAVE DEMOCRAT
WHITEOUTS IN THE SENATE AND
HOUSE.
I BELIEVE THE VOTERS ARE GOING
TO TAKE FRUSTRATION OUT ON THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEN IT WILL BE THE REPUBLICANS'
OPPORTUNITY TO GOVERN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GOVERN,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIX SOME
OF THESE PROBLEMS.
WE CAN'T JUST TALK ABOUT IT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I THINK GETTING SPENDING UNDER
CONTROL AND TRYING TO REVERSE
OUR ENERGY POLICIES, OBVIOUSLY
WE WANT TO SECURE THE BORDER, WE
THINK THAT'S CREATED A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH RESPECT TO CRIME
AND DRUGS IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO WE HAVE A PRETTY CLEAR AGENDA
WITH RESPECT